LAURENCE MORONEY: So Lucasz,
you work on Tensor2Tensor,
which is like a set.
It's a library
dataset that's really
designed to make
machine learning
more accessible, right?
Could you tell me all about it?
LUCASZ KAISER: Yes, it is.
To me, it's a follow-up
on the work on TensorFlow.
TensorFlow is now
used by many people.
It's a great system, at
least the foundations
for machine learning.
We found that it's still
quite hard for people
to get into machine learning,
to start, get their first model,
get some system working.
And then you can start going
from there, tweaking, tuning.
There are a few tutorials, but
then you get stuck on them.
There is a limit
to what you can do.
So in Tensor2Tensor,
it's a library
where you can get the data,
get the models, train them.
Get a working
system, but then we
know you can also go further,
get more complicated systems.
We do research on it
so you can really try
to do difficult things with it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So when
you mentioned get the data,
so there's known datasets
out there that you've
packaged as part of this?
LUCASZ KAISER: Yes.
We've packaged a lot
of the datasets that
are used in academia, image
classification datasets.
There is a dataset
of digits that's
like the "Hello World"
of machine learning.
LAURENCE MORONEY: MNIST.
LUCASZ KAISER:
It's called MNIST.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
LUCASZ KAISER: And
there are many more.
There's CIFAR.
There are larger datasets
like ImageNet, text datasets,
captioning.
There are a lot of
them so we package them
so you don't need to know
where to download them from.
It's there.
But you also don't need to
know how to preprocess them.
Because there are
a lot of tricks
that people use for
preprocessing, for adjusting.
It's sometimes hard to find
them if you don't know them.
In Tensor2Tensor,
they're all in the code.
We explicitly point out,
here is the preprocessing
so you can read it,
know how it's done,
or you can just run it.
Then you get the data.
You have it.
You can run your
own models, or you
can run the models that
are there in Tensor2Tensor.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And that's
really useful to have,
because sometimes, you just
want to get straight to training
and executing on models, right?
Rather than needing to figure
out all the things that I need
to do for a specific dataset.
So if that's already
done for us--
LUCASZ KAISER: Yes.
On the other hand, sometimes
you have your own dataset
and you just want to run
existing models on it,
it can be harder
than people think.
In Tensor2Tensor,
you have the API.
You just make your dataset
adhere to this very simple API.
And all the same preprocessing,
all the same models
will be applied.
So you should get reasonably
good results just running
the existing models.
LAURENCE MORONEY: A common
concept in programming
is don't repeat yourself.
So if you've already
done the work
for preprocessing something, if
I put my data in that format,
then I'm not repeating.
LUCASZ KAISER: Yes.
It's an effort to put the
machine learning components
and best practices
on a single platform
so that not everyone has
to redo it every time.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
When I first started
looking into Tensor2Tensor,
one of the things I noticed
is that a lot of the
things in Tensor2Tensor
are described as "problems."
And can you describe what you
mean actually by a problem?
LUCASZ KAISER: Yes,
in the simplest case
we say MNIST is a problem.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
LUCASZ KAISER: You want to
put in an image of a digit
and get out which digit that is.
And MNIST is a dataset
that has supervised
examples of this kind.
But some problems
are unsupervised.
You just get the image
and then your network
should figure out the digits.
Some problems are
kind of reinforcement
learning problems.
You just get some signal.
This was good.
This was bad.
But it's coming from an
external environment.
So we are trying to make a
single interface so we can
package these different things.
If you put it as a
problem in Tensor2Tensor,
you're guaranteed that the
models we have will run on it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Got it.
LUCASZ KAISER: If you're
coming with your data
or your reinforcement learning
problem, put it there,
and the existing models,
the baselines that we have,
can be run on it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
Yeah, because for me, like
as I've been doing it,
one of the things
I've been doing
is I've been just
trying to find raw data
and then I'm
preprocessing that data.
And then I'm training a model.
But I don't have any
context like, what are
the best ways to preprocess it?
The best ways to
format the data?
Do I normalize it?
Do I not?
You know, all those
kind of things.
So if, instead of
thinking in those terms,
what I'm able to do
is just shape my data
according to Tensor2Tensor,
and then you'll have--
LUCASZ KAISER: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: --prewritten
code that will work for me.
LUCASZ KAISER: Yes.
It's certainly a great thing
to do once or twice to learn.
Do everything
end-to-end on your own.
Take a course.
Do a tutorial.
But what we found out in Brain--
we've been doing research on
these topics for years now--
after your 10th model, you
don't want to redo everything
from scratch.
And maybe you want to
compare with your model
from a year ago.
It's really great to have
these things organized, tested,
maintained, working.
And I think this really
makes machine learning
more accessible to a wider
group of people, which is one
of the goals in Google, right?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah, exactly.
And also, it's like-- because
it's open source, right?
So some of the things that
you do for preprocessing,
I can go and take a look.
LUCASZ KAISER: Yes!
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
I can learn from that.
So if I want to write
my own preprocessor,
I can learn from
what you've done.
LUCASZ KAISER: And we
strive for a little bit more
than just open sourcing.
We really try to keep
the code readable.
Because you can open source
code that's very hard to read.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's true.
LUCASZ KAISER: We're
trying to keep it organized
so you'd know where to look.
There is a preprocess function
in every problem class.
And you know, OK, I need
to know the preprocessing
for this kind of data.
I look there.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Some
of the coolest things
that I've seen
Tensor2Tensor do is actually
generation content, right?
You've done some
Wikipedia generation.
LUCASZ KAISER: Yes.
So we--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Or should
I say Wiki generation
rather than, right?
LUCASZ KAISER: We have
classification models,
but we work on
generating text a lot.
And one example of generating
text is translation.
You take a sentence
in one language
and then generate, say,
a sentence in English
that's a translation.
You generate it,
usually, word by word.
But it's a lot of
fun to just let
it generate without
conditioning on anything,
just say generate
some sentences.
And for a single sentence, it
might not be that fun to read.
But we train this on
whole Wikipedia articles.
Wiki is a great dataset.
It's large.
It has a lot of articles
with nice structure.
And we see that it can generate
wonderfully coherent things
that are really hard to
tell from real articles,
but totally made up.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So what
do you write articles about?
LUCASZ KAISER: We had--
every time you generate
because you sample,
something different
can come out.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
LUCASZ KAISER: So we sampled
and once came out an article
about a Japanese music team.
It has a composer.
It has a name--
I think Motohiro Ohta--
totally made up with Google.
There doesn't seem to
be anyone like this.
LAURENCE MORONEY: If you're
watching, Motohiro, thank you.
LUCASZ KAISER: It
sounds reasonable.
And it has sections, when
the band formed, who joined.
It has a section on
when they performed.
They performed
with Led Zeppelin.
So it clearly learned some
knowledge about the world,
like what are band names?
What do they-- who
do they perform with?
It has a period in
which it exists.
And the dates make sense.
And then the band is to break
apart with Motohiro in tears.
[CHUCKLES]
So it generates a longish story.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'm in tears,
too, I never got to see them.
[LAUGHS]
LUCASZ KAISER: Yes, but
then you run this again,
and you get some fake book
or some fake TV series.
I like the fake TV series.
It had like seasons
and names of episodes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, wow.
LUCASZ KAISER: It was like
about a boy in the suburbs.
It has a summary.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Oh, this is great.
So I mean, if I'm a
writer, I can get ideas
by having this thing
throw articles at me.
Another thing that I saw
that you've been working on,
there was a blog post recently
about generation of poetry.
LUCASZ KAISER: That was
done together with Lak
from Google Cloud.
And he's a technical writer.
And he said, well, you're
saying machine learning is
accessible with this library.
Let me be the guinea pig.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
LUCASZ KAISER: Let me try
to do something I make up
and see whether it's
really easy enough to do.
And he said, OK, why
not generate poetry?
You're generating text.
I would like to
generate some poems.
He says, there is the
Project Gutenberg,
which is a large database
of open literature.
He wrote a script that
selected some poetry and said,
let's train on it.
Let me try.
Can I hook up this
data into the system?
Train one of the models on it.
Will it work?
And he did it, and
it didn't work.
Well, he trained, but
the model was not good.
It was not tuned to
this kind of data.
He says, well, but we
have automatic tuning
for the models.
Let me see how I can do that.
And he tried and tried,
and then it worked.
And he wrote a whole
blog post how to--
I love this,
because it shows you
if you come with your own data
and want to get something,
how do I actually do this?
And it goes through
the whole experience.
And at the end,
there is actually
a service which you type a line
and it continues your poem.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I've tried it.
That was fun.
And I've put a link in
the description below.
And it wrote better
poetry than I can.
[LAUGHS]
So if I wanted to get started
to do this kind of thing--
maybe it's poetry.
Maybe it's song
lyrics, or whatever--
and I bring my own data,
what advice would you give?
How should I get
started with it?
LUCASZ KAISER: Well, go to
Tensor2Tensor on GitHub.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
LUCASZ KAISER: Or check
out the poetry blog post.
You can install it and try
to run from the command line.
We also have Jupyter
notebooks, Spyder notebooks
where you can see step
by step what's happening.
Also, inspect the data,
especially if you do images.
Actually seeing what's
coming on input, what's
supposed to come on
output, what's actually
coming on output is
a very useful thing.
So there is a notebook
where we step by step show
you what to do.
Go to the website.
Try it out.
And also, thanks to a
lot of my colleagues,
it's a very active project.
We work on it every day.
We work with it.
We work on it.
So you can start with the
small things, like poetry.
It's a very small dataset.
You can train in a few hours.
MNIST, you can train
in two minutes.
But you can move on.
Like with the Wikipedia, we also
did just Wikipedia generation,
but we also did Wikipedia
conditioned on web searches.
So it doesn't make things up.
It's actually factual.
It generates things that the
internet says about people.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I see.
LUCASZ KAISER: And this
data set is 8 terabytes.
It takes a bit longer to train,
but we still open-source it,
thanks to the
common crawl, which
has a large part
of websites online.
It's possible to actually
do this-- well, at home,
I don't know.
But at a university, you can
get this really large dataset.
You can run
state-of-the-art models.
So it's a platform where you
can start small, but really
go big with time.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
So Tensor2Tensor,
and it's on GitHub
as part of the
TensorFlow project.
LUCASZ KAISER: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So cool.
Well, thank you so much, Lucasz.
This has been so much fun.
I've learned so much.
And thank you, everybody,
for watching this episode
of "Coffee with a Googler."
If you have any questions
for me or if you
have any questions for
Lucasz, please leave them
in the comments below.
And also, don't forget to take
a look at the description.
We've put links to everything
that we spoke about.
And also, we have a brand new
TensorFlow channel on YouTube.
So be sure to check it out.
Thank you.